- The hash tag bluemonday
has been trending all day
'cause scientists say today
is the most depressing
day of the year.
Well-planned premier
date, Comedy Central.
(laughter)
(applause)
Many corporations
use that hash tag
to promote their products.
Famed cleaning product Mr. Clean
- [Audience] Awww.
- Never forget.
(laughter)
tweeted which of the
following cries for help
with the hash tag bluemonday?
A. Apparently this is the most
depressing day of the year.
Explains why it took three
hours to get out of bed.
Hash tag bluemonday.
I don't think I like
humanized Mr. Clean.
- [Andrea] No.
B. Mom, stop asking when
there will be a Mrs. Clean.
Hash tag bluemonday.
(laughter)
C. The one thing I can't clean
is the blood off my hands.
I wish I could bring
back those villagers.
We were so young.
Hash tag bluemonday.
(applause)
I mean, it's called Mr. Clean
'cause he was
special ops, right?
He would come in if
you needed to solve a-
Paul Scheer?
- I'm gonna say C, I think
that that's 100% right.
I wish it were C, I tell
you the correct answer is A.
- [Andrea] Oh my God.
- I know this is the most
depressing day of the year.
Explains why it took
Someone get that guy an ice
cream sandwich or something.
- He's been cleaning
for his entire life,
just give him another
day of a break,
(laughter)
I mean, he has a terrible life.
- I'm so tired of seeing my
own reflection in toasters.
(laughter)
The monotony.
- I do wonder if that tear
would actually be better
than anything else that he uses,
like a real tear from Mr. Clean?
- Well, that's where the
cleaning product comes from
- [Paul] His tears!
- Yes, they come from
Mr. Clean's tears,
which has the high concentration
- With like a bottle
- of cleansing power and
so all day long, yeah.
The government sent him
to Nam as an experiment
to get the most thorough
cleaning product
so all of his flashbacks
mean clean appliances
for you, the consumer.
- When he went up, he
would light up a village
and fill up 17 gallon jugs.
(laughter)
- But some of those tears
were mixed for villager tears.
(laughter)
- [Chris] They were, yes.